la mode fin de partie c'était cette
semaine la grande semaine des
collections de printemps à paris nous
vous en avons parlé dans nos dernières
éditions
couturier toutes griffes dehors et
journée hystérique bien sûr pour les
mannequins alors c'est pourquoi à notre
tableau d'honneur ce soir un mannequin
dalmat bonsoir dalmat je précise que
vous êtes d'origine brésilienne j'espère
qu'on va vous voir ça y est on vous voit
bonsoir dalmat alors vous êtes mannequin
vedette vous être reconnu dans le monde
entier
vous avez même l'année dernière remporté
un prix très très convoité à new york
l'année dernière alors simplement je
voudrais vous demander combien de
collection vous avez présenté cette
semaine
cette semaine j'ai présenté à peu près 7
cette collection oui cette collection ça
veut dire bon cette collection pour la
semaine mais ça veut dire chaque jour
par exemple combien de fois vous êtes
habillé déshabiller en est là ce
vraiment énormément peut-être 400 x 300
fois parce que ces normes afin je
pourrais pas seulement sur paris je
contrôle paris un peu partout mais ça
parce que vous êtes un mannequin très
convoité un mannequin vedette ça veut
dire que vous vivez ou d'abord moi je
vous dis non pas votre adresse
personnelle je vous demande elle vivait
mais vous n'êtes jamais à new york j'ai
tout le temps partout
oui peut-être le villes du monde ah oui
et normalement je voyage beaucoup parce
que bon ben là c'est seulement métier il
faut gagner voyages surtout ici alors
que j'aime beaucoup
alors dalmat vous savez que être
mannequin c'est un métier très très
convoité par tous les jeunes à peu près
aussi convoité que présentateur de
télévision alors simplement est-ce que
ça fait mal un certain nombre d'années
que vous le pratiquer ce métier est ce
que avec le recul vous trouvez que c'est
un métier formidable
ah oui bien sûr parce que je trouve
qu'ils ça nous apporte beaucoup
on peut faire tellement peut voyager on
peut connaître des gens différentes
alors c'est vraiment c'est excitant
c'est aussi
très occupée par on est toujours un
courant ont couru on attend alors c'est
quelque chose qui bon c'est ça prend
beaucoup mais c'est super on voyage on
est jeune et belle valeur sûre si on
gagne de l'argent
pas mal samad oui combien combien bah
écoute assez pour vivre bien vous
voyagez vous faire la belle vie qu'est
ce qu'on fait après parce que bien sûr
c'est un métier enfin je veux dire c'est
comme les footballeurs professionnels
enfin c'est pas tout à fait pareil mais
ça veut dire que c'est un métier qu'on
ne pratique que quelques années qu'est
ce qu'on fait après mais après je ne
sais pas mais qu'il est tellement des
options et là il ya des gens qui vont
faire le cinéma il ya des autres qu'ils
font quelque chose dans la mort il ya
des excuses à la gauche que vous coupez
peur mais je ne sais pas si tu es le
vous écoutez maintenant vraiment aucune
idée et peut-être se passer quelques
annales comme bien m'aider j'aime bien
le message est transmis
merci beaucoup d'allemands voilà